[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien d'entre vous est jamais les ou
carnaval de québec
jamais ne savait quoi faire en février
c'est parfait combien d'entre vous
jamais vécu des grandes transformations
dans sa vie personnelle des grands
changements intérieurs jamais genre je
pense qu'elles sont là parce que je
trouve qu'on oublie ce manque d
organisation s'est constitué
d'organismes des gens comme vous et moi
qui vivons d'espoir de projets de
déception de grandes peines parfois et
que si on vit ça à une échelle
individuelle forcément ça se reflète
dans nos groupes sociaux que ce soit
dans nos familles avec nos amis nos
clubs sportifs mais aussi au travail
le carnaval de québec fait pas exception
à la règle et je pense que nous tous on
découvrait environ trois grandes mouture
du carnaval de québec
les plus âgés je devrais pas les plus
vieux les plus âgés vont se souvenir
d'eux si la rue sainte-thérèse les
sculptures de glace à petit chat de
caribous qu'on pouvait boire chez
l'habitant
les gens de ma génération vont se
souvenir du gros party qu'étaient
devenus les défilés pro marocains etc
s'en souviennent pas d'ailleurs puis les
plus jeunes vont voir profiter du virage
familial que eu lieu à la fin des années
90 on constate donc que le carnaval a
toujours su se réinventer et ça c'est
quelque chose que je trouve très
passionnant mes collègues et moi on a
décidé de mettre en place
c'est quelque chose que je trouve
vraiment fascinant et j'ai décidé
d'investiguer ce genre de truc là en
fait il ya une révolution que ça perd
dans le domaine du travail peu importe
le champ dans lequel vous devrez l'idée
c'est de renverser le paradigme
traditionnelle qui veut que le haut de
la pyramide de systématiquement pour le
bas de la pyramide on s'est rendu compte
qu'en fait ça valait la peine de
s'intéresser à ce que vivait le bas de
la pyramide
parce que c'est eux qui appliquent des
règles qui teste des produits qui ont un
lien direct avec l'usagé comme artiste
je me suis toujours intéressé à
l'aventuré humaine par le biais d'un
paquet de médium
puis comme tailleur culturel job dans le
milieu de la production culturelle soit
multimédia cinématographique mais en
événements beaucoup depuis plusieurs
années et c'est une drôle de bibitte de
l'extérieur ça a l'air super glamour
super cool je vous dis pas qu'on n'a pas
de plaisir dans tout ça
mais il ya aussi un retrait effréné
souvent des comptes sans travail qui
nous amène à travailler à contrat
courait après les contres bien autre
chose c'est que les équipes aient pas
souvent du simple aux quadruples en
l'espace d'à peine quelques semaines
pour après se dégonfler une espèce
d'effet accordéon ce que j'ai remarqué
au fil des ans et qu' il ya des effets à
sa hantise effet là c'est le fait que la
passation d'information suit pas
toujours
d'année en année d'édition en édition ou
que les outils sont pas tout à fait
adaptée aux besoins d'une organisation
simplement parce que les gens ont fini
leur contrôle ils partent et continue ça
à mon intéressant un point tel où su
retourner aux études sur le tard comme
le dit tantôt d'une françois je vais
aller en angleterre faire une maîtrise
dans ce programme librement traduit par
imagination appliquée dans l'industrie
créative
je vous le confirme qu'en revenant au
québec en 2013 gonflé à bloc
craquez d'avoir appris tout ça quand
j'ai mis ça sur mon cv déjà atypique
sais pas ce qu'il en était à me trouver
de la job en tout bon c'était une
question de temps mais de beaucoup de
patience parce que je me retrouve
maintenant depuis à peine six mois
direct la programmation et d'innovation
au carnaval de québec le carnaval de
québec
c'est une super gagne dont je salue le
courage parce que ça en place
j'ai eu plein de changements dans les
dernières années puis ils surfent sur
cette vague là non seulement sur la
vague des changements organisationnels
et en plus on me suis dans mon volet
innovation même s'ils savent pas tout à
fait où je m'en vais avec mes skis et
pour ça je les salue parce que ça prend
du courage et de la bravoure le carnaval
donc c'est une quarantaine de personnes
avec des profils hyper varié qui
travaille ensemble on a
traditionnellement déjà les finances aux
communications à la production mais on a
aussi une équipe aux ateliers contrat
avec des soudeurs des sculpteurs des
couturières
puis tout ce beau monde là toute la
journée se côtoient comme des agneaux
sociale je trouvais qu'il y avait
tellement de richesse là dedans à
exploiter je vais vraiment quand on
exploite les maillons possible autour de
toi moi je parle du fait qu'on est tous
multi facettes convient tous avec un
bagage diversifiés et que qui me dit que
c'est pas notre super réceptionniste
aline qui aurait la solution une
problématique à nos couturières aline
qui me dit que ce n'est pas notre
contremaître roger qui a une solution à
la problématique en programmation
mais si on crée pas un espace pour
explorer ses possibilités là on ne saura
jamais ça devient une belle perte
d'opportunité en réalité on vous a parlé
de design thinking vous avez peut-être
au travail entendu parlé de méthodes
comme âgées l'escroc sommes peut-être
que les post-it de couleurs les
marqueurs sont atterri sur vos bureaux
et à ça je dis y est par contre ce sont
des facilitateurs et l'innovation
à mon sens du aucune solution pérenne en
innovation qui va pouvoir rester si on
crée pas d'abord un seul plein un espace
a créé un espace où tout le monde a le
droit d'exprimer des idées même saison
folle même si t'as pas l'argent pour
même si ça se peut pas deux prototypes
et des choses qui fonctionnent repos la
première fois d'échanger et dans cet
espace là on essaie de laisser
l'extérieur nous réflexe pin oublier
qu'on a tous comme être humain c'est
tout à fait normal
le cynisme est pas permis le négativisme
et pas permis de dire qu'on n'est pas
assez bon c'est pas permis
c'est vraiment un bel exercice pour
créer pour innover et pour ça je
considère qu'il ya trois piliers
importants nécessaires à la mise en
place d'un cf plus particulièrement au
travers une intention être capable de
dire aux gens qu est ce qu on veut
qu'ils se manifestent avec l'accent
composent l'empathie et la gratitude au
carnaval on a donc créé le carnot lab le
canal en fête est née dans mon esprit
you un ennemi bien avant que j'entre en
poste au carnaval
quand j'ai regardé les premières
changements qui s'opèrent et on sortait
des plantes sous de strictes tellement
une belle opportunité de soutenir le
changement puis d'aider les équipes à
travers tout ça par le design tanguay
comment ça se manifeste
ça peut être l'arrivée de temps en temps
on a des invités externe qui nous
présente comme un traître l'innovation
dans leurs champs d'expertisé ou dans
leur compagnie ça peut être des ateliers
pour développement dans neuf étant au
mois de septembre avec 40 personnes tout
le monde les ateliers tout le monde
était rassemblé pour travailler ensemble
mais hier on ne te tenue ainsi
dîner-causerie on était dix c'était
l'invitation ouverte pas encore parlé
d'une ovation
c'est aussi apprendre à regarder nos
problématiques avec notre fameuse cpm
comment pourrions nous améliorer un
produit comment pourrions-nous avoir une
meilleure visibilité
mais c'est aussi quelque chose qui me
tient beaucoup à coeur c'est aller
chercher de la rétroaction qui ceint
pendant le commentaire parce que je le
dis souvent moins qu'on me dise c'est
super ou ses poches ça m'aide pas
amélioré quelque chose donc quelle est
la problématique pourquoi c'est une
problématique comment vous suggérer la
réponse de ils répondent pardon mais
toujours garder le petit ici le ici
c'est la portion de rêve c'est la
possibilité créer une banque
peut-être des idées complètement folle
mais qui pourrait nous servir plus tard
savent où se dire prototype et un défilé
vous en avez eu un aperçu jeudi de
nouvelles annonces qui s'en vient
vraiment super existants et on travaille
son prototype et ceux des fléaux
également ça se manifeste aussi par des
petits gestes le coeur de la gratitude
c'est un simple coup de chiffon qui se
promène entre collègues qui permet aux
gens ne se remercier pour un geste pour
un petit coup de pause pour un bon mot
qu'on en avait besoin
puis pour moi ce c'est quelque chose qui
peut répertorier sortie post facebook on
s'en remet au pot des emails c'est dans
l'intimité des collègues qui se
partagent un merci le cfp laisse
l'espace sacré faut aussi pouvoir le
délimiter pour cela j'utilise mon gris
gris qui se trouvait une petite
guirlandes colorées qu'on dépose au
seuil d'une porte de conférences ou de
son bureau pour indiquer aux gens que
leur ont fait un effort pour sortir de
nos réflexes pour est dans l'ouverture
dans le champ des possibles qui compte
invite les gens à nous accompagner là
dedans
la petite clochette en forme d'étoilé
elle permet simplement dangereux de se
ramener à l'ordre quand quelqu'un tombe
dans ses réflexes d'être cynique ou de
descendre de pourquoi son potentiel
quand on parle d'innovation en
entreprise pour moi la meilleure image
pour leur présenter ses l'aspiq parce
que vous trouviez que ce soit pour vous
la une un délice ou une aberration
culinaires et en reste pas moins que la
gélatine dans ces fêtes du collagène
d'ailleurs dont on est tous constitués
c'est ce qui permet à tout les petits
éléments hétérogènes de tenir en place
mais colin j'en ai dans le l'audience
on entend souvent dire maintenant de
sauver
il faut que le jello pogne je dis
souvent ça pour moi une belle façon de
faire pogner le jello c'est vraiment par
l'innovation travail
j'espère que vous allez trouver moyen de
faire pogner le jello mais je vous
garantis que vous avez pas à les fermer
très allantes pour la faire il ya
d'autres façons de le faire tout
simplement merci
[Applaudissements]